[Música]
eu sou especialista em medicina do sono
ea gente sabe que a temperatura corporal
oscilou ao longo do dia e logo depois do
almoço existe uma queda da temperatura
que corresponde momento que a gente tem
mais sonolência
então se você dormir em fique à vontade
o professor estava praticando sem
problema nenhum
agora eu acho que isso já foi falado
anteriormente que a tecnologia em si ela
simplesmente está dando a oportunidade
da gente enxergar as coisas de uma forma
diferente e se a gente for ver pela
nossa definição de saúde doença segundo
a organização mundial de saúde à saúde e
ao bem estar físico mental e espiritual
e mais alguma outra coisa se eu
perguntar aqui quem que tem tudo isso ao
mesmo tempo ninguém vai levantar a mão
então como nós temos uma visão muito
idealizada de saúde
todo mundo fica o que o doente então aí
tem uma visão naturalmente errada e todo
mundo tá doente está todo mundo de
primeiro tá todo mundo com pressão alta
refluxo se você for somando as doenças
que nós temos não cabe na face da terra
porque está todo mundo doente ea
tecnologia está permitindo a gente
enxergar essa situação de um jeito
diferente
a verdade é que os ingleses que gostam
de pensar sobre esse assunto tem
discutido que saúde é a capacidade que
você tem de lidar com novos desafios é
uma mudança total de paradigma que só
pode ser e existir
à medida que a gente conseguir
monitorizar as coisas de uma forma
diferente porque se eu for um médico e
medir a pressão arterial a minha
primeira pergunta é doutor na minha
pressão está normal então eu só tenho
saúde ou doença não tem outra opção
agora se eu conseguir medir alguma coisa
ao longo do tempo
e eu vou perceber que as coisas ou se
não ao longo do dia ea gente vai ter a
possibilidade de dizer
será que eu estou conseguindo lidar com
esse desafio nesse momento pra mim
porque dizer que estresse é uma coisa
ruim não é verdade eu estou estressado
de tac mas ao mesmo tempo isso me dá uma
energia e uma vontade de compartilhar
com vocês essa ideia que na realidade é
uma mudança radical de paradigma que não
tem absolutamente nada a ver com a
tecnologia em si
se a gente for falar de sono por exemplo
se você pegar o seu celular você
consegue baixar uma centena de
aplicativos que medem horário certo de
dormir a quantidade de sono a qualidade
do sono
as fases do sono e até o horário de
acordar o problema é que nenhum desses
aplicativos foi validado e a gente tem
uma tecnologia que a gente não serve
para alguma coisa a gente não sabe pra
que serve pelo menos para a gente
perceber que nós somos uma sociedade
privada de sono a gente dorme cada vez
menos e esse é o mais novo padrão de
sono a gente apaga a luz mas continua
conectado de manhã o despertador toca e
tudo o que a gente está falando vai pro
brejo porque quando você está cansado
nada disso funciona agora quem já que eu
vou pedir pra vocês levantarem a mão
quem já que tem todo me e de repente do
seu lado tinha alguém roncando
tremendamente e você não conseguiu
dormir levanta a mão por favor
é uma quantidade é absolutamente
incrível mas eu fico preocupado com
aqueles que não levantaram a mão porque
quem ronca é o outro eu não ronco minha
mulher que está aqui na segunda fileira
diz que o ronco e eu não acredito e é
uma doença curiosa agora vamos dar uma
olhada nessas pessoas que roncam existem
roncos e ronco se você rompeu de vez em
quando
de barriga pra cima tudo bem as mulheres
sabem disso dá uma cotovelada no sujeito
ele vira de lado e melhora tudo bem é só
que agora ele de lado continua roncando
virou que profissional e lyon que
qualquer posição
são vocês estão rindo mas isso pode ser
um indicativo de uma doença
tremendamente grave e comum que é a
apnéia obstrutiva do sono e o que é
apnéia então vou pedir pra vocês agora
eu vou contar até três e vocês vão fazer
uma peneira vocês vão parar de respirar
vamos lá você em casa também 123 parem
de respirar segura aí e eu vou contando
a história da apnéia do sono sujeito que
pára de respirar durante o sono ele tem
que parar por pelo menos 10 segundos em
cada evento pra gente considerar isso um
evento de apnéia obstrutiva do sono pode
respirar porque a maior parte não fez
mas quem fez vai perceber que antes de
você parar de respirar ou sem insuflou
os pulmões você encher o peito de área
isso é uma resposta natural do animal
que mergulha o paciente que tem apnéia
do sono não é isso que acontece porque
ele está roncando eo ronco significa a
obstrução parcial da passagem de ar
quando ele está respirando a verdade que
a garganta do ser humano é muito
estreita
nós cometemos um erro terrível se você
acreditar na teoria da evolução dos
nossos primos os macacos tem o queixo
aqui nós dominamos o fogo é a maxila ea
mandíbula foram projetados para trás e
resolvemos sair da árvore então a via
aérea faz uma curva ea nossa garganta é
estreita e não tem nada que a gente
possa fazer a respeito disso e aquele
sujeito estava roncando de repente ele
solte o ar e na hora que ele vai
respirar de novo ele encontra uma
garganta fechada
e aí você fala bom agora eu vou dormir
porque ele parou de roncar bom é nessa
hora que ele parou também de respirar e
ele está tentando respirar e não
consegue
e aí então que ele faz ele tem um micro
despertar tem aquele ronco alto
ressuscitar ativo você estão rindo mas a
doença é grave
e essa pessoa eu costumo brincar e dizer
que essa pessoa sabe dormir e saber
respirar
ele só não consegue fazer as duas coisas
ao mesmo tempo quando ele dorme a
garganta fecha esse quadro fica se
repetindo isso causa cansaço sonolência
ea gente ter estudado muito
agora a relação entre a apnéia do sono
principalmente por causa das quedas
cíclicas de oxigênio com pressão alta
arritmia cardíaca e risco aumentado de
acidente vascular cerebral infarto agudo
do miocárdio
o diagnóstico é feito através da
polissonografia você passa uma noite no
laboratório pole são vários onu grafia o
registro de vários canais durante o sono
e o que chama a atenção dessa doença em
um estudo feito há três anos atrás
publicado pelo professor sérgio tufik
com mais de mil indivíduos
representativos da cidade de são paulo
de 28 30 anos escolhidos pelo datafolha
foram fazer a polissonografia ea
prevalência de apnéia do sono é 33%
isso significa que você está sentado aí
se a pessoa do lado direito não tenha
apneia olha professor do lado direito e
se a pessoa do lado esquerdo não têm
apnéia
provavelmente você tem apnéia do sono
a gente sabe que não é assim que a
estatística funciona mas provavelmente
você conhece alguém muito próximo da sua
família que tenha apneia do sono e não
diagnosticado porque essa doença é um
problema mundial
segundo a academia americana do sono
num estudo publicado há dois anos atrás
a cada ano existe uma perda de 260
bilhões de dólares por conta do subgrupo
de apnéia do sono a pessoa tem
diminuição da produtividade a pessoa tem
é risco aumentado de acidente ea pessoa
tem aumento de comorbidades
a boa notícia é que existe tratamento
você pode colocar uma máscara nos casos
mais graves ligados a um compressor que
os e papi puxa mas eu não consigo dormir
com isso consegue sim porque os e papi
melhora muito a qualidade do sono ele
joga um pouquinho de área garganta uma
plaquinha de avanço mandibular nos casos
mais leves feito pelo dentista dormir de
lado perder peso e exercícios como
escultura existe uma infinidade de
tratamentos possíveis mas a gente
precisa fazer o diagnóstico e eu tenho
orgulho de participar de um
trabalho multidisciplinar coordenado por
um engenheiro
tácito almeida que está sentado aqui na
segunda fileira e nós estamos
trabalhando junto na solução desse
problema e nós estamos trabalhando há
mais de três anos e todo o laboratório
do sono está agora na minha mão já que
os celulares existe na na cabeceira de
todos nós
nós juntamos um pequeno aparelho aqui
que acabou de ser aprovado pela anvisa
então isso não é mais um garoto já está
por aí e ele está sendo validado você
coloca no dedo e agora você pode fazer
várias vezes durante a semana por
exemplo a gente sabe que existe uma
variabilidade um dia a gente dorme
melhor ou pior
e esse aparelhinho você tem em casa
essas informações vão para o celular vão
para a nuvem voltam e são analisados
rapidamente a gente acredita que a gente
vai conseguir mudar o paradigma do sub
diagnóstico da apnéia do sono não no
brasil é lógico que a gente quer fazer
isso no brasil mas este é essa solução
serve para o mundo inteiro e para
terminar eu gostaria de desejar pra
vocês tudo que foi falado anteriormente
paz amor sucesso é a plenitude e assim
por diante mas nada disso faz sentido
sem uma boa noite de sono então pra
vocês eu gostaria de desejar uma boa
noite de sono muito obrigado pela
atenção
[Aplausos]